uh Donald Trump is absolutely Furious
that Republicans are telling him stay
the hell away from Georgia there is a
senate runoff in Georgia of critical
importance on December 6th it is Rafael
Warnock the incumbent Democrat against
Republican Challenger Herschel Walker
the winner on December 6th will
determine do Democrats hold the Senate
50-50 needing com needing every
Democratic vote and then Kamala Harris
as a tiebreaker to get things done or
you Democrats take a 5149 uh Helm of the
Senate making either Joe manchin or
Kirsten Cinema a little bit Irrelevant
in getting things passed it's very
important there is of course this guy
named Donald Trump who's running for
president in 2024 he wants to be seen as
the Savior and the winner everywhere
despite his pretty bad endorsement
outcomes in the November 8th 2022
midterms and Republicans seem to
recognize if Trump comes to Georgia to
quote help Walker it might actually be a
really bad thing and there's a very
interesting uh Rolling Stone article
Trump is pissed Republicans keep telling
him to stay away from Georgia it's by
Aza wind subsang and Nikki Ramirez with
a runoff election looming they write the
newly announced 2024 candidate doesn't
want his Rivals getting any attention
while his party Wards him away
and they write as Republicans poor party
resources into the Georgia Senate runoff
Donald Trump is getting irritated at the
idea that virtually no one of importance
wants him to campaign in Georgia in the
lead-up several Republicans and Trump
allies already told him not to hold the
Georgia rally ahead of the runoff
according to two people familiar with
the matter
Trump has however suggested that those
close to those close to him that he'll
react poorly if Florida's governor Ron
DeSantis campaigns in Georgia while the
Republican Party holds its once
Undisputed leader at arm's length people
who have recently spoken to Trump fear
if DeSantis announces a Georgia event it
would guarantee that Trump also heads to
the state Trump has also vehemently
argued to AIDS and confidence that his
presence in the runoff would be a net
positive for Walker and he's accused
pundits and Republicans who say he
shouldn't go to Georgia are
unintelligent Trump haters I want Trump
in Georgia I really do hold rallies talk
about how the next election is going to
be rigged and how the previous one was
rigged and it was stolen and it was all
stolen stand right next to Herschel
Walker and say this is one of the people
we need to get in there but it was
rigged and how where's my
African-American and all the crazy stuff
do it I think it will be bad for
Herschel Walker if Walker wins there is
obviously something very wrong with the
people of Georgia
and the fact that Warnock didn't win
outright and we need a runoff I've
already said complete and total disaster
I'm uh no no question whatsoever
we are where we are right now which is
that the 2.1 percent of the vote that
went to the Third Party candidate could
go either way and it's going to come
down to turnout and it's going to come
down to ground game I can think of few
things worse for Walker
than what was bad for other candidates a
few weeks ago which is Trump showing up
ranting for 90 minutes or two hours
about voter fraud and how he did really
well in 2020 and then kind of saying
yeah and vote for this guy or gal
it wasn't good for the contested races
it wasn't good for mastriano it wasn't
good for Oz it wasn't good for Tudor
Dixon it wasn't good for Kerry Lake J.R
Majewski lost John Gibbs lost and on and
on and on so I say bring Trump to
Georgia and let him wreak havoc even
better would be if it becomes for lack
of a better term
a penis size contest between Trump and
DeSantis to the detriment of Herschel
Walker we know that Barack Obama will be
campaigning with Rafael Warnock if the
scheduling lines up we will cover that
live and if indeed this sort of slurry
of uh Republican rallies with Trump
DeSantis Etc materialize for Walker we
will cover those as well but most
importantly and I know I've said it
before and I'm going to say it again
most importantly
if you live in Georgia
if you're registered to vote in Georgia
make sure that you vote because this one
is of critical importance make sure also
that you're subscribed to our YouTube
channel if you're watching right now on
YouTube and you look at that subscribe
button up there or down below wherever
it is
and it's enabled if it says subscribe
rather than subscribed hit that button
there's over three million people who
watch our videos and don't yet subscribe
help us get to 2 million subscribers
we're gonna take a quick break and be
right back
parents in the audience if you're like
me you're looking for fun new things to
do with your kids meaningful enriching
but fun enough to keep them engaged
every month our sponsor Mel science
sends you a box with science experiments
that combine Hands-on Physical
components with virtual and augmented
reality learning science doesn't need to
be boring it doesn't need to be
difficult many kids are Hands-On
Learners who absorb the most through
activities like these it's perfect for
homeschooling ages 5 through High School
five different subscriptions to choose
from chemistry physics stem math or
medicine Mel science sent me the
chemistry of monsters box where you grow
a black monster from sugar and make a
huge foam eruption in a flask but you're
actually learning about carbon dioxide
and unstable carbonic acid we had a ton
of fun with it the VR components are
awesome too it is really clear how this
helps kids tune into what they are
learning and my audience gets 50 off
your first month go to melscience.com
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below